I think the climate change issue has
been politicized from the very beginning
and Copenhagen is not the failure of an
issue it's a political failure
the climate change based on still not so
much facts but on computer models has
led politicians to take several
decisions which I personally have a big
problem with the most important one of
course is biofuels apparently to solve a
problem of co2 which was pointed out to
be the most decisive aspect of climate
change which personally I don't think it
is it is one of many I don't think it's
the only one but by having concentrated
on this only one politicians took a
decision that it was for example good to
substitute oil through biofuel now if
you look how much water you need in
order to produce one liter of biodiesel
it's 9100 litre of water to produce one
liter of biodiesel it is four thousand
six hundred liters of water to produce
one liter of pure ethanol if you see
those figures if your then see that one
hundred thirty thousand tons of maize
were transformed we're at the same time
people didn't have enough to eat you
start to ask yourself whether those are
the right decisions and I think a
several of those decision has been made
on a political scene without really
thinking it through what it means the
whole process has come under questioning
and I think that's what really happened
in in in Copenhagen it was a political
failure it was not for me at least an
issue I think the issue is there I think
it is wrongly presented
I think climate change is much more
complex than just co2 and you see that
now for example finally people
understand that madam is almost 20 times
more aggressive than co2 and then you
will see their lot of other greenhouse
gases may reminder that there was once a
Montreal agreement before there was a
kyoto agreement where we also talked
about the greenhouse gases so and then
climate change had happened in the past
and will happen in the future so if we
look at the big ports of the Roman
Empire they are today all of them about
20 kilometers inside okay they are not
anymore at the sea so one could even see
could say well hopefully there would be
a little bit of an increase of the water
level because as I said we lost about 20
kilometers down